hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chest cube
gonna play another five minute game okay
here we go we have a game against uh tu
tu estoy I was just trying to spell it
out okay
rating wise 2365 so certainly a strong
player I think I've played this guy
before guy or girl maybe in like
chess960 so okay Bishop g2 is coming up
what should I be doing to prepare for
the bishop on g2 I'm just trying to
establish a pond in the center I'm not
try it is established in the center now
I just wanna I think simply develop get
my bishop outside my eventual pawn chain
I want to do this and now c4 strikes at
the center it also makes way for the
Queen to come out to be three thick just
east six sometimes I would like to meet
Queen b3 with Queen b6 I don't know if I
could really manage well yeah actually
I'm gonna do that let's run with that
okay so actually it's a little bit
awkward okay if Queen b3 I think it
might have been a little bit weird to
try and defend against b7 with my clean
if I played Queen b6 the Queen's are
traded doubled B ponds that are also
isolated are usually going to be an
issue whereas in the other variation if
I still had a C pond it wouldn't
wouldn't that be wouldn't be that bad of
a thing so now what going to be free and
could I just do it ignore it and play
knight c6 and just maybe try and get my
knight to be 4 and then c2 I don't know
if I really like that actually come to
think of it I don't think that there's
really going to be a problem with just
Queen d7 here sometimes that would be
something I'd be a bit afraid of if the
LightSquared bishop if I White's
LightSquared Bishop could let's say play
to that B 5 square but I don't we're not
going to have that
so just something to certainly watch out
for in the event white didn't go for a
fiend keto type of development for the
LightSquared Bishop and now just I guess
get this guy involved and now actually I
do want to play like this move next I
think because eventually naive White's
going to be playing Knight e5 and my
Knights going to be having to run here
so I'm going to do that right now
actually and if Knight takes I just
recaptured my Bishop and I think I have
I think I've just obtained equality
without too much problem here so that's
our the last piece that last minor piece
to get involved this is one of the more
dry type of openings here and the reason
the reason why I'm assigning the word
dry is because of the pawn structure
there's not too much difference between
both sides the pawn structure and now
I'm going to bring this rook over to the
only open file so that's it seems like
it makes sense it's in the open file I
don't know if there's too much of a
difference between which rook gets
played to that open file maybe I'm
seeing you know this pawn would need
some support and my book that was on the
F file I don't think that it was really
needed there so my queen is hit I got to
do something about that
and now I think I just take a couple
times on c3 and then bring my other look
over yep okay I'm just gonna go with
that and I think I'll be able to
actually gain control okay wow this is a
serious it's a very serious move right
there
okay that is a backward pond now how can
I target it my first thought is just
rook c4 rook c4 just to prevent that
pump pawn from even advancing I'm gonna
go with it alright is there maybe I
wonder a thought of g5 that's a little
bit crazy isn't it g5 with f6 to come
next no I think that's a bit too
far-fetched so I'm gonna abandon that
plan I think white has to play
3.now okay there it is III just to chase
my rook away but now now that bishop on
now the bishops trapped see that that's
a problem isn't it that's gonna be a
problem for why but actually the other
problem I'm going to be experiencing his
time okay so oh I did not consider that
particular move okay alright so let's
actually hit this guy first and do what
next okay could I actually what could I
do here take on a take on e5 hmm no I'm
not liking that okay not my rook is
being attacked and I better do something
about that recapturing with my pawn so
this kind of backfired on me well it
definitely did backfire on me I wasn't I
did not calculate deep enough there okay
f6 is just like pretty much a weakness
now so what do i do is back up I got a
minute left to figure something out
let's keep my bishop here I would like
to get my my Bishop to c4 but Bishop f1
is coming like right now to play rook oh
I'm going to be losing an exchange
wonderful okay let's uh let's deal with
that so try and take advantage of whites
light squares now that's my big plan at
this point
okay let's um maybe I can get my queen
in here see who actually I should have
just maybe played my bishop too
now that that wouldn't be good because
of the pinned the pin nature of my piece
is here my bishop would be just taken my
pawn is pinned to the Queen there so
let's actually go with this
I want my Queen to be able to recapture
so I have some compensation
I certainly have compensation because of
because of what the the weakened king
that white has but I don't know if
that's really going to be enough am I
going to be able to maid actually
okay let's try this if that rook moves
it's gonna be me we won't be seeing that
now what should i do my light square
bishop should I be able to could I get
it somewhere else
I've 36 seconds that's not not looking
too great
ooh that's just as serious yeah that's a
blunder was I really threatening
something very bad there I'm just gonna
win this end game okay and that's gonna
be it Wow
what is um what is why do okay this
wasn't the the greatest game here and
this is just gonna be turning out to be
me that's it okay um I'm not sure how
instructed that game was let me just
actually go back where could I have
maybe done better here it was certainly
a poor idea for me to and I'm not sure
how well you're able to even see it on
the screen right now because the board
does shrink down after the game has been
completed however let's let's take a
look at why maybe I went for no I didn't
mean to do that
let me back up why did I go for this f6
advance did I really think that I was
going to be able to trap that bishop
that was a serious problem okay actually
maybe here's a reason how I could maybe
correct myself in a future game nope
knowing that this the White Queen has
pressure on my rook means that my pawn
that's on d5 is restrained in a
particular way can only capture in the
direction of the C 4 square so I should
have maybe been considering that white
could at some point play this efore
advance and I don't have the option of
capturing you D takes e so recognizing
the pressure that's on my rook maybe
should have made me a bit more aware
that the possibilities White has with
this efore is you know it could could
very well show itself and so actually
backing up at this point I hear this
idea of rooks e4 could have actually
been met with just efore right away and
maybe that's something that Y could have
done too even
improved their own game but that's at
least one thing I think to maybe take
away from this game for myself and
hopefully for yourself as well so that's
all for this video as always hope you
got something out of it take care bye